[Musik]
die grönlandsee einsam und doch belebt
wale voraus auf diese nachricht haben
die passagiere der plan cius sehnsüchtig
gewartet so auch das ehepaar maria und
adrian nussbaumer
107 gäste sind an bord des
expeditionsschiffe soft kreuzfahrt von
spitzbergen nach grönland
er gehört zur besatzung reiseleiter
michael wenger
dann tauchen die meeressäuger endlich
auf weiß schnauzen delfine und finnwale
tummeln sich um das schiff
fahre begeistern michael immer wieder
aufs neue denn eigentlich ist der
41-jährige meeresbiologe
glaubt nicht daran dass ich gehen halt
besonders gut
reporterpool super
[Musik]
berlin
2 schäfer 2
exotische destinationen
war ja und adrianos baum aus würenlos
sind auf entdeckungsreise in der arktis
in der letzten folge nahm reiseleiter
michael sie mit auf landgang auf die
insel übte orlowski in einem fjord
entdeckten sie eisbären
sie sind immer noch verliebt erst seit
vier jahren ein paar die aargauer astrid
leni und ostermayer gemeinsam mit
ehemaligen schulkollegen geboren 1947
aus bremgarten sind sie auf einem
jahrgangstreffen der besonderen art der
karibik ein höhepunkt bisher war die
kapitän skala bei ihrem ersten stopp in
nassau auf den bahamas entschieden sie
sich für eine inselrundfahrt
die tour beginnt
freddy tellenbach war die letzten 20
jahre voll für seine handelsfirma im
einsatz nun könnte sich endlich ferien
die bahamas bestehen aus 700 inseln
außerdem haben wir mehr als 2000
korallenriffe
gibt es jedoch industrie
tourismus ist die nummer eins dann
finanz und bankenwirtschaft
landwirtschaft und fischerei kommen an
dritter stelle
dann geht es in die innenstadt von oslo
ein verkehrspolizist erheitert die
gemüter
[Gelächter]
so viel spaß hatte freddy lange nicht
[Musik]
zurück im hafen auf der brücke der l
europe the seas dem größten
kreuzfahrtschiff der welt bereiten der
kapitän und seine offiziere die abfahrt
vor
unter ihnen nicola college er ist der
erste offizier
der 30 jährige kroate fährt bereits seit
seiner jugend zu sehen
gut das war es du machst dein buch
weiter du am achterschiff und auf der
brücke setzen wir nun stufe gelb
offizier nick ist heute auf dem
sogenannten montag eingesetzt dort
werden die tower eingezogen noch sind es
mehr als eineinhalb stunden bis zum
auslaufen
die passagiere kommen nun nach und nach
zurück an bord auf der brücke müssen wir
wissen wie sie ja noch fehlen damit wir
die vorbereitungen entsprechend anpassen
können denn es braucht zeit bis das
schiff abfahrt bereit ist
die plan cius hat nach zwei tagen auf
see grönland erreicht erster stopp das
dorf die tore mit mit seinem freiluft
passbüro
[Musik]
longyearbyen spitzbergen war der
startpunkt der 13 tägigen kreuzfahrt von
dort ging es über die insel ihren oscar
nach grönland
sie ist doch was ist los wenn wir dort
das war ja und deutsch ist frei das war
maria adrian und die anderen passagiere
haben nun drei stunden zeit das dorf zu
erkunden
[Musik]
es zieht sie in den dorfladen nur
zweimal im jahr wird er mit waren
beliefert
burlage dass die nation am schlimmsten
gewesen daraus ist auch rückzug war er
schon vor der wende zu besuchen
das angebot umfasst lebensmittel und
haushaltswaren
darüber hinaus aber auch dinge die maria
und adrian in dieser einsamkeit nicht
unbedingt erwarten
im souvenirladen nebenan suchte
reiseleiter michael geschenke für zu
hause
michael ist von den polarregionen
fasziniert da hier verbringt hier rund
20 wochen im jahr in eisigen gefilden
die lange abwesenheit belastet seine ehe
schwierig ist es
ist mein job ihn sprachen
ich finde nicht in kompromissen
aber es ist nicht einfach
in nassau machen die aargauer einen
fotostopp
[Gelächter]
freddy staunt über figuren aus alten
getränkedosen doch viel zeit haben sie
nicht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
man muss sich im griff bekam
mit musik geht freddy das herz auf in
der schweiz spielte mit kollege guido in
einer transparent
[Musik]
jena
wir haben da einiges euro
und aegon street zurück
aufs schiff und der ausflug hat sich
gelohnt
[Musik]
die schweizer kommen pünktlich zurück zu
schicken
ganz im gegensatz zu vielen anderen
30 minuten vor abfahrt fehlen noch rund
200 passagiere
[Musik]
das ist eine weite strecke bis saint
thomas daher müssen wir fast die ganze
zeit mit maximaler geschwindigkeit
fahren
wir dürfen nicht mit verspätung starten
passagiere die nicht rechtzeitig an bord
sind müssen sie zurücklassen
[Musik]
120 schälen
es verbleiben 15 minuten
offizier nick steht in ständigem kontakt
mit der brücke von dort erhält er
anweisungen die ersten vier tower
einzuziehen
dann kommen die letzten beiden
passagiere angefahren gerade noch
rechtzeitig nick nimmt es gelassen ich
liebe es zur see zu fahren das diesen
besonderen schiff zu arbeiten es gibt
sicher viele die mich in diesen job
beneiden zudem ist der verdienst nicht
schlecht genug gründe also die heimat zu
verlassen vor allem wenn man bedenkt
dass die beruflichen möglichkeiten zu
hause deutlich schlechter sind
red
die ausfahrt aus dem hafen von nassau
ist heikel nick kontrolliert den abstand
zum ufer oben auf der brücke sieht man
das nicht
[Musik]
das schiff bewegt sich ganz langsam
wir dürfen auf keinen fall noch näher
ans ufer kommen das wäre sonst sehr
gefährlich wir sind jetzt schon die ich
tragen
wir sind pünktlich
das ist immer gut jetzt ist der kapitän
glücklich
und wenn ihr es ist sind wir es auch
[Musik]
von fort lauderdale ging es nach nassau
als nächstes ziel lockt die karibikinsel
saint thomas der zweite stopp der
siebentägigen kreuzfahrt
[Musik]
landausflug in bluhms druckt der blumen
bucht
[Musik]
reiseleiter michael erkundet mit einigen
passagieren die arktische flora
[Musik]
auf deutsch das arktische weidenröschen
ist die
inoffizielle nationalblume von grönland
und heißt übersetzt junges mädchen nicht
ganz so nicht mehr ganz so schön offen
aber
nichtsdestotrotz
durch die sachgebiete oder richtig gut
drin bist und einheimische tiere
untereinander miteinander guides und ich
sage wie sie denn
das wüsten als pitts müssen aber die
verschiedenen anderen aspekt das sind im
falle dass pflanzen aber nicht die
ursache ganzen ärger besser dienen als
andere
ziel ist eigentlich dann einen schönen
aussichtspunkt zu kriegen dass man ein
bisschen auf den blick auf die bucht hat
michael begleitet heute die
strandpiraten eine gemütliche gruppe die
auf eine längere wanderung über stock
und stein verzichtet
großteil von derzeit
genau dort einfach natur
und action
sie haben wir schöne aussicht auf die
tundra und den den
schneebedeckten gezuckerten bergen im
hintergrund
das ist genau das was für schätze wenn
sie sich ruhig ist natur das genieße ich
erst wenig bis kein zivilisations lang
und ab und zu passiert bis in
den abend rechnen
archäologische schnee haus
in diesem grünen bereich des so den hang
hoch geht
da
ist ganz da ist oben sitzt ein
schneehase
auf dem großen schiff geht programm rund
um die uhr im aquatheater läuft die
nachmittags schon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der kapitän ist teil der show und da
steht für einen smalltalk zur verfügung
astrid linie und ostermayer lassen sich
das angebot nicht entgehen die
kreuzfahrt ist ihre erste gemeinsame
fernreise
[Musik]
durch
während astrid noch ein foto mit dem
kapitän möchte hat uns ein anderes
anliegen bis zu seiner pensionierung war
er bergmeister bei einer firma die
restaurantküchen herstellt unter anderem
auch für den mega liner
ich bin aus der schweiz und habe die
küchenmaschinen für dieses schiff mit
entwickelt
fantastisch küchenmaschinen für die
allure of the seas ja für die allure die
bases und anderer schießen
alle wissen dass die schweiz gute
produkte herstellt
max
aber in der sache
richtig
in den griff
auf seine küchengeräte ist uns stolz er
hofft sie bald im einsatz zu sehen
[Musik]
frühmorgens in grünland reiseleiter
michael ist wie immer einer der ersten
über 1000 meter hohe berge erheben sich
rings um das schiff in solchen momenten
sammelt michael energie für den tag
dass ich behindert
sorge bereitet ihm allein das wetter es
ist viel schlechter als vorhergesagt
eigentlich untypisch für den praktischen
spätsommer
nun gilt es die passagiere bei laune zu
halten das weiß auch expeditionsleiterin
delfino des
guten morgen es ist viertel nach sechs
wir befinden uns am fuß des sunrise
mountain leider noch ohne sonne
[Musik]
typisches grünen werte wir sehen auch
ein ex-militär von der linken seite
können wir nichts machen wir wissen
deswegen gestoppt und
wir können auch sagen wenn die schönes
wetter haben wollte dann wären wir
wahrscheinlich nach mallorca gebracht
also wenn ihr es kommt einfach eine
wasserdichte schicht mehr an wurden im
regen schön nicht
[Musik]
aber nicht nur das wetter ist schlecht
auch die stimmung bei einzelnen
passagieren
[Musik]
sonne in der karibik die allure of the
seas nimmt kurs auf die insel saint
thomas
[Musik]
offizier nick hat das kommando auf der
brücke
seine einsätze dauern jeweils zehn
wochen dazwischen hat er mehrere wochen
frei
der hafen ist ziemlich eng das macht die
anfahrt kompliziert
wir müssen auf den schiffsverkehr achten
momentan ist das aber kein problem es
gibt nur ein paar kleine fischerboot das
wetter ist schön daher hoffe ich dass
alles gut gehen wird
nick trägt viel verantwortung das schiff
ist eine schwimmende kleinstadt 18 decks
hoch 3 162 meter lang es bietet platz
für bis zu 8500 menschen offizier nick
steuert es nur mit einem joystick
wir nähern uns der insel haben aber
immer noch eine hohe geschwindigkeit
gleich kommt der luzern sehen wir müssen
also vieles beachten ich bin nicht
nervös aber sehr konzentriert
jetzt ist sein thomas schon ganz nah die
insel gehört zu den amerikanischen
jungferninseln und ist beliebter stopp
für kreuzfahrt touristen
von hus
präziser findet der ozeanriese seinen
weg in den hafen von charlotte mit der
hauptstadt des archipels
die araber wollen an den strand nicht an
irgendeinen sondern an den schönsten der
inseln
[Musik]
die mccanns bay ist ein traumstrand wie
aus dem reisekatalog
doch guido kann einfach nicht aus seiner
haut
doch das stimmt sehen
guido will nicht baden er will lassen
astrid und urs hingegen sind verzaubert
eine süße
ja ja nein
ja richtig gehört
das leben das ist absolut der branche so
oder so fahren
die das wasser die sind richtig gegen
das fahrzeug auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
irgendwann kann auch nicht mehr
widerstehen
und während die männer getränke holen
bereitet astrid mit kollegin mary eine
überraschung für guido vor
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die hand die kraft reichte
[Gelächter]
ein geburtstagsfest in der karibik das
hätte sich guido damals in der schule in
bremgarten nicht träumen lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf der brücke der l you of the seas
wartet offizier nick auf das ende seiner
wache sechs stunden dauert eine schicht
gleich hat der pause
[Musik]
es kann ruhig sein aber auch hektisch je
nach situation
das ist meine frau
ex frau ist mit den kindern zu besuch
einen monat lang ist die familie an bord
das ist nicht bei allen reederei möglich
als ich mich für die laufbahn auf see
entschied machte ich mir keine gedanken
oder die schattenseiten des jobs
ich war 14 träumte von weißen und formen
großen schiffen und viel geld
jetzt bin ich dort wo ich immer
hinwollte
das zu bekommen musste ich auch etwas
geben
in der arktis regnet es seit stunden die
passagiere der plan cios sind zurück vom
landausflug
[Musik]
warum sie im namen der user noch
21 logisch
ich hoffe noch kraft auch die
hausordnung sehen sie das
genau
mal ist
reiseleiter michael macht inzwischen
pause in der crew messe da ist die
besatzung unter sich thema auch hier die
erwartungshaltung der passagiere
danke ich glaube für den
sollte sich nicht zu stark unter druck
setzte quelle der waage halten
offizier nick und seine frau vera wollen
mit ihrem sohn rocco in die stadt
tochter nikolina bleibt auf dem schiff
ihr ziel ein sportgeschäft sohn rocco
braucht neue schuhe
wir sind uns nie einig wenn ich einen
schuh aus woche findet sie ihn hässlich
anders herum fragt sie mich nicht einmal
und er möchte sowieso alles kaufen
vera und nick sind seit fünf jahren
verheiratet ihre beziehung ist geprägt
von nähe und distanz
dabei sind es die alltäglichen dinge die
immer wieder zu kurz kommen umso mehr
genießen sie nun die gemeinsamen stunden
mit
der trennung auf zeit hat sich die
familie gezwungenermaßen arrangiert
ehrlich gesagt sind die zehn wochen auf
dem schiff ziemlich gut
ich war es gewohnt viel länger auf sie
zu sanieren
jetzt kommt es mir fast wie eine
belohnung für
im vergleich zu sechs oder sieben
monaten an bord sind zwei monate
wunderschön
jetzt ist es viel einfacher ich arbeite
daneben habe ich die kinder da geht die
zeit schnell vorbei
ja
in grönland hat zumindest der regen
aufgehört nun zieht reiseleiter michael
seine trumpfkarte polar schwimmen ist
angesagt
adrian ist hart im nehmen die
wassertemperatur erreichten über knappe
0 grad
[Gelächter]
für sie aber
schlecht
zu stehen
ich mir schon mandoline
[Musik]
ein tierisches highlight in centers ein
leguan beobachtet das bunte treiben im
hafen
[Musik]
an bord machen os und emil für einmal
ihr eigenes programm
us möchte gerne die küche sehen an der
er vor einigen jahren als werkmeister
mitarbeitete
dazu braucht er das okay des
hotelmanagers
[Musik]
so wenig war da ist die krise noch nach
dem trio
us hat glück tobias frieden burg der
zweite küchenchef nimmt sich ein paar
minuten zeit
entsprechen das ist genau das was wir
brauchen und das ist das auch gesagt
die stadt braucht
einfach auf mich zukommen ja ja und hier
arbeit einfach
ja noch konstruktionsmethoden
polizei das macht mich wie ein stock
vorerst ins stocken sie dafür die
hygiene
faszinierten
jugendmannschaft also ich jetzt noch
irgend jetzt alles ist passion
der blick hinter die kulissen ist ein
privileg
passagieren wird er normalerweise nicht
gewährt
[Musik]
früher schwärmten sie für die rolling
stones heute findet man die gruppe aus
bremgarten im jazzclub
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine messe intermot 27 c rohr gang sind
so will aber mit taschen und schuhe burg
wir sind sowieso zweck rostock
und dennoch der
damals
zusammenkunft daher oder mit folgen mit
25 mb/s konnte nach der kollision
bis jetzt
denn wir sind der privaten zusammen und
das müsse
ein bisschen
ein vergnüglicher abend im kreis der
freunde manchmal braucht es abstand und
zu sehen was im leben wirklich wichtig
ist
[Musik]
in grünland geht es am morgen zum
rohlinge gletscher tief hinein in einen
fjord diese fahrt ist für viele
passagiere der absolute höhepunkt der
reise für solche erlebnisse haben sie
viel geld bezahlt
auch maria und adrian freuen sich schon
lange darauf die eismassen aus der nähe
zu sehen
druckluft eigentlich am meisten surprise
bord eines systems moleküle
eine gewisse druck jetzt denn
richtig krieg krieg berlin
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
turmhoher eisberge sind vom gletscher
abgebrochen und treiben richtung offenes
meer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
was ich jetzt ist wo komplett ohne
lufteinschlüsse x trac ii schlösser
speziell in den usa sendet und ganz ganz
nicht die luft fliegen die luft kann er
ansonsten komplett durchsichtig was
schönes kaleidoskop
glasklaren
mich erfüllt und warum ich noch einen
sieg und sie und seine freundin dann
kann man eine
man halte doch schön unsere unsere
sicherheitsabstand
die gefahr eisbrocken könnten sich lösen
und das schlauchboot treffen um das
schlimmer es zum kentern bringen
[Musik]
in der karibik geht die kreuzfahrt dem
ende entgegen die allure of the seas
nimmt kurs auf fort lauderdale
es sind vielfältige eindrücke die guido
von dieser reise mit nach hause nehmen
wird
[Musik]
kompakte
[Gelächter]
nur kaufen
was ich sicher so dass man da an luxus
an du hast
ja wo ist es dass sie also für mich
jetzt
20 oder nicht nur volk aus der
heimerfolg auf sky und
ich habe da sitzt und danke es freut
mich auch nicht und schlacht christian
ist gar nicht
das personal doch alles so super
von vereinzelten
so
reis
auch astrid und usa sind die kreuzfahrt
noch einmal revue passieren
jetzt könnte man noch die westlich
machen tempo
eines ist sicher astrid thors und die
anderen werden sich bald wiedersehen bei
einem foto abend zu hause in bremgarten
[Musik]
in grönland blauer himmel und
sonnenschein als ob sich die natur mit
den passagieren versöhnen wollte
[Musik]
auf der plan cius sorgt zum schluss ein
grillfest für gute laune
der stamm zu nehmen und sich
lässig und werde ganz bestimmt sehr
verhalten erinnere geblieben
[Musik]
auch bei reiseleiter michael werden die
karten neu gemischt für ihn endet die
saison in der arktis noch in ein paar
wochen wird er im südlichen polarmeer
wieder an bord der platz muss gehen der
job im eis lässt ihn nicht los
über 40 extrem
verpasste
[Musik]
es ist schwierig zu sagen ich persönlich
würde gern weitermachen
den umstand dass es anders zu holen
kann ja auch nicht das weiße
salbe
wenn dir einer so oft irgendwo
angekommen
ansonsten fällt mir raten ist
[Applaus]
und so schließt sich der kreis für die
passagiere ist die arktis bald nicht
mehr als eine schöne ferien erinnerung
für michael hingegen die passion seines
lebens
[Musik]
[Applaus]